and it was improvised this thing so I
wanted to show what I could do
so you had to improvise your way into
this movie or out of this movie and
depending on what you did or didn't do
you were in it or not in it and so it
was a very weird structure but
um dysfunctional group actually it was
it was not super fun Sandra Oh was in it
Daryl Hannah Sandra Oh and I got to work
together she's so wonderful but I
auditioned so you had to make up a
character
so I made up a character and came in and
a friend of mine helped me
because we know it was in this triple
world and he was a male stripper a gay
dude one of my best friends and he
helped me make up this character so I
brought this character in and and oh my
God it was in a theater so they had all
the people auditioning just sitting in
the theater watching you watching you it
sucks it sucks I like to be by myself
with nobody I don't want people to hear
me yeah I hate that it's horrible and
you're stuck there for three hours
because each person is going down doing
their thing right then I got a call back
so in our world you do the same thing
you did you don't change your shirt you
don't change nothing because you want to
do what you're doing something right
doing something right so I go back in
with the same character and they're like
what are you doing here with the same
character
and I'm like wow you really want me to
make up another character
like you can just you know like like I'm
on freaking SNL you know what I mean uh
oh I auditioned for that too so anyway I
did make up five characters for that but
ah that was that was an interesting day
wow you gotta love actors we're game man
but back then did they at a certain
point make you take off your shirt to
see if so then because they can't do
that now right no they can't do it now
but they did because then
um Michael called me and said he said
they said all right you know Michael was
there they said all right you'd do the
same character and but I did different
stuff because it's improvised so that's
also awful and terrifying so then he
called and said I want to have lunch
with you so he said look I love you I
want to hire you you're incredible but I
gotta have Daryl Hannah because she puts
butts in seats and she's also incredible
but I had gotten there first but you
know her name came in and then I had to
step aside as you do so then I get a
call that so they've been in rehearsal
for months improvising in this crappy
theater on Santa Monica months in a room
stripping there's a stripper pull the
whole thing and they call me and say
it's our last day Friday
show up
and bring what you got and we'll see if
you can we can work you into the movie
in a scene or two
I sit there for like five hours in the
hall trying to stay in my head in
whatever character
then they go come on in and the other
girls are all dancing and the music's on
and they're pretending that they're in
the oh God even worse first it was play
improv games
so they all know that improv warm-up
games I've never done improv so to me
this is just
stupid
okay so I do the stupid improv games and
then then we get to well we're in the
the rehearsal room and so it becomes
that I come in and they all hate me and
I'm like okay do they really hate me or
this are we improving okay we're
improving so Daryl Hannah doesn't really
hate me but there was no like hi Kristen
nice to meet you just went to our Crazy
Crew it was like I walk in the room and
they immediately they were living it
like okay not used to that
so then I just went all right so then
they go yeah this is Nico she's going to
be headlining so I'm like headlining
okay so I'm the headliner so this whole
thing evolves and then everyone starts
taking their clothes off
in this I'm I'm auditioning so I go [ __ ]
it take my clothes off in the audition
in this this improvisational room yes
you just took your shirt off yes and
your pants yes you got naked naked and
everyone else did yes you're nude and
I'm their nude with everybody how many
people are in the room there's like all
the actresses from the thing like six
actresses the director some other
producers we're all just naked
[ __ ] it I said [ __ ] it and you did it
and you weren't scared I was petrified I
was shaking
and I was like okay this is the film and
I'm I was just being crazy and brave I
guess really more brave because this was
the role and I knew that so and they're
all naked so I'm like all right you know
what you wanna and and they're being Was
Daryl there yeah she was naked naked
what on the pool she was crazy Daryl
Hannah's naked going crazy on a pole
you're naked everybody's naked The
Producers this has to be the best day of
their lives the best day of their lives
and and they might have been in like
perverted lives yes and they might have
been I don't remember who else was like
had on Bottoms or someone had a top on
or whatever but we were all like pretty
much in our skivvies
and then I get a call going you're in
the movie
okay
[Music]
and they go so you're playing a porn
star
and there's going to be an outline so I
get the outline script and it says
no dialogue or anything but it was like
Nico goes on stage to do a striptease
and
it's so incredible no one wants to go on
the stage and follow her
that's and I'm like no pressure
now these girls have been for three
months in stripper School
I I call and go uh what what do I do
that is better than the splits which I
can't do and what I saw Daryl doing on
the poll Sheila Kelly who produced and
starred in the movie started you know
the strippers the exercise thing S curve
or something it's called yeah all around
town these Housewives Are are in LA on
polls doing exercise classes on a
stripper pull that's her
her she's made probably Millions she's
so good she's hanging upside down but
you had no class you had no experience
nothing you just got up there and winged
it nothing I can't even touch my toes
I'm not flexible I mean and I'm like are
you [ __ ] kid what am I supposed to do
but you did it they go well figure it
out
so I hire
Michelle Pfeiffer's whip trainer from
Batman
no joke and I go dude teach me a whip
routine because I can't touch my toes I
can't do pull I went to stripper school
for a week and was and hurt my shoulder
I I mean have you seen the scene
yes and did you like it it's so it's so
over the top because here's what
happened after months of working with
the whip guy and I even rehearsed on the
set
I show up
and they've lowered the ceiling all the
lights are hanging down and on the day I
can't do my whip routine because the
whips hits the ceiling because the whip
hits the ceiling so you had to scratch
that I
oh my God if I would have known what a
panic attack was I would have known I
was having one but I could barely
breathe I was like I have nothing then
they bring in all the extras then the
room is lit brighter than an or because
on film it'll look darker
and there's a hundred people there and I
have no routine
and I'm oh and then I had picked the
song Echo and the bunny man yeah but
they couldn't they said we can't play
the song because we're gonna have to put
it in later in post
and I'm like
uh oh my God I can't do this